well a las vegas doctor is working with
patients even after two women died due
to complications from surgeries he
performed an investigation began after
the eight news now i-team started asking
questions well now one victim's family
member is calling out the medical board
for what she calls just a slap on the
wrist the i-team's vanessa murphy has
this exclusive story
i'm going to try really hard
you know to move on and just stay
positive for the kids deborah mann is
trying to grieve the loss of her niece
but what makes it even harder she says
are what she believes are failures by
the nevada state medical board we just
stay close and supportive
and think a page every day in 2018
deborah's niece paige hazelton went to
dr steven gordon for a brazilian butt
lift it's a cosmetic surgery where fat
is taken from one area of the body and
transferred to the backside to make it
appear fuller according to the clark
county coroner during page's surgery fat
traveled from her muscle to her lung
causing a blocked artery the 30 year old
mother leaves behind two young sons she
would have never left her children
and we miss her very much
paige didn't know that another woman had
died after going to dr gordon for the
same surgery four years earlier when the
eight news now i team started looking
into paige's death we found two previous
settlements with dr gordon for 950 000
for a wound infection after a surgery in
1997
and another for nearly 700 000
that was the result of the death of
adriana mendes rodriguez in 2014. she
was a 38 year old single mother of two
girls an autopsy report states her
organs were perforated during the
liposuction part of the procedure no
disciplinary action had been taken
against dr gordon until the eye team
started asking the medical board
questions in 2019. they could do
something about it
they could save another life alejandra
lawler is adriana's twin sister 17 days
after the i-team first reached out to
the medical board this four-page
complaint was filed against dr gordon
alleging medical malpractice this was
five years after adriana's death dr
gordon then admitted to malpractice and
had to pay a twenty five hundred dollar
fine along with paying for the cost of
the investigation he was also
temporarily banned from performing
brazilian butt lifts your investigation
led to a lot of facts that we didn't
know going into this you know there was
no information on the medical board this
complaint filed in february of 2021 in
connection with paige's death also
charged dr gordon with medical
malpractice
it states he didn't discuss the risk of
death associated with the surgery and
didn't obtain written consent from page
that acknowledged the risk of potential
death the settlement filed a month later
states dr gordon isn't admitting to the
claims but to resolve the complaint he
is admitting to malpractice they let him
say he's not guilty
and then they
in the next paragraph he has to say i'm
guilty dr gordon received a public
letter of reprimand and this time he had
to pay a five thousand dollar fine and
again the cost of the investigation the
agreement also states he shall complete
100 hours of community service providing
medical care to the needy along with 22
hours of continuing medical education
when you read this document i mean the
it's so
protective of the doctor the eight news
now i-team requested an on-camera
interview with the executive director of
the medical board he declined but he did
answer some questions on the phone and
by email today when you look up dr
gordon's information on the medical
board's website his license is listed as
active we asked why the executive
director pointed to this section which
does mention restrictions we also asked
why it is still not clear on the website
that two women died during surgeries dr
gordon performed page's death is
mentioned but not adriana's the
executive director says nevada state law
requires medical malpractice be reported
but not the type of harm that's related
to it he's being protected by the
medical board
not given consequences in my eyes it's
so upsetting
it was
it was just beyond my belief page's
family sued dr gordon the board's
website lists a 950 thousand dollar
settlement we reached out to the
attorney who represented dr gordon for
his cases with the medical board and did
not receive a response by deadline dr
gordon's cosmetic surgery practice
closed and according to the medical
board's website he was working at a burn
center at sunrise hospital a spokeswoman
for sunrise says his medical staff
privileges there ended last year vanessa
murphy live local now
in 2018 a task force of medical
societies issued a warning about
brazilian butt lifts that procedure is
considered the most dangerous kind of
cosmetic surgery with an estimated death
rate of at least one in 3 000 that
warning came just a few months after
paige hazelton died